well James Earl Jones is arguably one of
the greatest voices in the history of
cinema you know his voice has been
associated with some of the great
characters I think like the one thing
everyone always says about James Earl
Jones and so cliche it's true it's just
that that voice that voice that deep
voice and that mischievous smile well I
mean he's the voice of Darth Vader so he
wins really knows how to accessorize you
know the the black cape and the chest
buttons I still have I still have a
helmet at home that I'd meant afraid to
say I put on occasionally james earl
jones i worked with and the exorcist too
so i have some wonderful fond memories
well the two of us being awarded the
Daniel bum theatre world award for best
new actress on Broadway and my squeaky
voice when I said this thank you very
much and his butyl soon aureus fantastic
voice it's just like velvet you always
hear that you're like lamp or should I
had a voice like that i have this
squeaky irish voice i want a deep
baritone soothing voice like that of
course I'm well known for a certain
voice and he's well known for certain
boys he's very charming and he's a
prankster oh well that little smile you
know and he has that little Snaga tube
which has become quite of appropriate
but he has this big voice but is it just
a little little boy inside I think a lot
it in like that he's amazing and this is
huge huge gentle don't it just ignore
that one tonight I wrote something for
him a tribute to him because
he actually is the only actor who has
reduced me to sobbing after one of his
performances it just broke me apart I
mean he's been in so many films and we
saw the great white hope the other day
you realized his career was going to be
brilliant Field of Dreams to me is like
it's just one that like I have seen that
movie 700 in 55 billion times I still
can't get through it it still destroys
me and he has such a strange ability to
be completely open and wildly strong at
the same time and it's that's a really
interesting mix to watch so he's been in
movies that have moved us in and made us
laugh and cry and think makes you think
he's been nominated never won so
watching him get that tonight I think
smiles on everybody's faces his acting
is just unbelievable and it's finally
that you know that he's getting
recognized we're so proud of that
you